[Musik]
das wahre Leben ist sich für andere
einzusetzen wir die Pflegefachkräfte von
morgen mit kogniturl der Versicherer für
Gesundheit und Vorsorge
[Musik]
vielleicht rettet Ihnen eine vor deiner
jungen Mannschaft
sie sind Orgien die Flagge von Kraft
oder retiksonde drin auswählte strangend
[Musik]
wir die Pflegefachkräfte von morgen
Notfallstation
Pony ist mit der Amelie unterwegs eine
erfahrene Kollegin
sie sind unterwegs zu operen
zuständig das wird als Priorität 2 also
nicht lebensgefährlichen unterwegs
aber wo sie dann auch hier mit Situation
anders aus
schon morgen
und auf halb Stunde
wenn man merkt dass die Situation für
Patient lebensbedrohlich ist
kritisch okay
unregelmäßig und
er schlau ja Abbruch wir helfen euch
gerade er braucht sofort
Schlacht seine
Schock 20 Minuten
bis sie da sie
normalerweise nicht ja absolut okay
vermutlich
der Betroffene
Schlaganfall
abklären und das sehr schnell
was los ist
[Musik]
am Mittag
alles klar also Planänderung
[Musik]
die betroffene bewusstlos langsam
vom Alfred voller bläulich hat viel
Erfolg
[Musik]
Postfiliale Montblanc in Dampf
seit vier Jahren
Kolleginnen und Kollegen für
Verabschiedung
Marie taucht als erstes
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ja sie wird mir schade ja
für die übrigens
gemacht
[Musik]
wir sind wieder bitte von ihr und dem
Alfred wo war gerade unterzuckerig knapp
gegangen ist seine Frau josian hilft mit
und hebte Büttel mit dem Zucker
[Musik]
jetzt wird der Blutzuckerwert wieder
kontrolliert er ist schon vor 1,9
[Musik]
guten Tag hallo
beauftritt ist ziemlich unfreundlich zu
der retik Sanitäterinnen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
widerspruchsaft trotzdem muss mit der
Zuckerwert alle drei bis fünf Minuten
kontrollieren
passiert
das Sanitäterinnen entscheidet ihre Mama
Spitals bringen ein Moment zum dorischen
Hofer
super viel verdient
und dann haben wir unter Druck gesetzt
[Gelächter]
wirklich starke
Operation für die Remo Edition
also wieso fangen schon irgendetwas
intensiv das ist doch viel üblicher
wie sie sich um mich kümmert für den
Alarm wo ständig läutet will grad
angeschlossen ist trotzdem lachen
nein die linke Seite
spürt er sie
Narkose
eine sehr starke Schmerzen wenn du Zeit
Spezialisten
es gibt zwei Teams wo auf schwarze
spezialisiert sind unsere
Seite wird und nicht wie sie eigentlich
gemacht
sehr starke Schmerzmittel Prinzip ist
das
in fünf Minuten verstanden
[Gelächter]
gemacht und sind Freundinnen geworden
richtige Worte und das ist schön dass
wir da aufeinander
und der
Patienten
fertig
ja genau
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
durch chirurgieabteilung auf sie ist es
letzte Praktikum
vorsichtiges Thema vom ansprechen
wisst ihr was plötzlich heißt dass man
immer sagen
das macht mich schon Angst trotzdem
wesentliche Bestandteil
jetzt
also
bist du ja ja aber ohne Frage schade
[Gelächter]
Privatklinik hat jeder Patientin eigenen
Arzt deren begegnet gerade
zum sich kennenlernen der ursprünglich
Bruch muss ich vorstellen
Deutsch
interessant
für Medizin oder Biologie
immer spannend und man
lernt Vermittler
ja genau
das sind Schrauben
[Musik]
und ich finde mich
ein bisschen lustig sagen okay ja
gut danke
[Musik]
bitteschön
am besten haben wir sich doch bedanken
gegenüber der Pflegerinnen oder Pfleger
wo sich ständig um ihn kümmern
nicht auf dem Tabletten
dass man sauber dazu
organisieren dass man Make-up Pfeife
etc also Weg finden mitmachen
[Musik]
spitzsburg
richtig
neue Abenteuer war für mich
während der Praktiker sind die junge
Flagge von dem härterprüfsalltag
konfrontiert und stöhnt unter Druck dass
du jetzt Alien aber nicht mutiger also
verschiedene Optionen was einem Moment
gefällt Abteilung
ausprobieren
für andere Abteilungen oder was
da wird auch jede verabschiedet wird
[Musik]
sie hat sich selbstständig gemacht und
werde daheim Flagge
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
Spital Porsche Praktikum
guten morgen morgen
die ehemalige Uhrmacherin kümmert sich
rund um durum
[Musik]
und ja jetzt ist sie einfach an der
Punkt
immer raus für ihn er macht es nicht
müde
ja drauf gewartet das Restaurant immer
aufmachen aber das dürre nur also drinne
sauber kaufen
Flaggen die ankündigen Mühe hilft ganz
tolle wenn Sie das Gefühl heißt
es gibt viel was ich schuldig fühle und
weil sie da wo sie sich darum kümmert
Handy Spital bringen
wir probieren dann in die Schuldgefühl
austreten
und dazu ist aber so dass die ankündige
wo Pflege
als die eigentliche Patienten genau
wie lange sind sie schockiert
[Musik]
und sie ständiger
es geht Tag was gedacht
Resultat von reporteranalyse und
Urinprobe zur Verfügung
theoretisch ist es klar aber praktisch
man muss es nach einer Minute halten
mit einer Teststreifen nicht so einfach
darum bin ich froh dass sie mit Dachau
Kolleginnen
und wie es richtig zu lassen
diskutiert mit dem hilfspflagger seriell
wie es weitergeht
du findest es vielleicht grausam
und ja
unbedingt sagen
[Musik]
Rehabilitationszentrum
die ganze Geschichte geht eben schon ins
Herz wenn man sich mal bewusst macht
360 Jahre das ist das
Zukunft bringt aber wenn im Spital ist
und eine andere Struktur
zieht länger vor wie wir sie beide im
Spital wäre ich der Moment macht ihr
seid sicher sicher
zwei Wochen später hat dann Marie Spital
wieder Verlass
Sanitäter
sobald sie mit der Ausbildung fertig ist
wird Pfanne in eine eigene Wohnung
ziehen wenn Kinder mal so weit dann
haben wir diese Job gemacht und das ist
doch gut sie sind unabhängig und ich
glaube so gestalten wie sie es war und
das ist doch dass ich doch
zusammensitze am grosse Tisch wo viel
los ist das ist Geheimnis von der
untertrennliche Familie davon
[Musik]
Tradition verpflichtet dem Essen macht
immer mal wieder rappert und Scherz
und sie hat angefangen so mit Sachse
[Musik]
mir überlasst nicht es passt zu ihrer
das ist nicht verdammt
dir die Familie aber sie selber hat
andere Zukunftsplan ihr werdet schaffen
aber keine Familie aber das
Problem aber nicht eigentlich
für die nächsten 50 Monate
40 Jahre als Rettungssanitäterin
schaffen das ist Stefanie ihre Traum für
Zukunft
[Musik]
nächste Woche
psychologische Arbeit
[Musik]
Rebecca betreut den Patient mit Autismus
und findet den guten Draht
[Musik]
das war wir die Pflegefachkräfte von
morgen mit Öl der Versicherer für
Gesundheit und Vorsorge